to you know, some customer feedback. Uh
there are there I I realize there are
still a high percentage of people that
are still on NT7 and they want to use
the Order Flows Trader with NT7, not
NT8. So, if if you fall into that
category, we've updated our NT7 version
of the Order Flows Trader 2.04
NT7. And you know, people say, "Why why
would I use NT7 still if NT8 is the one
that's going out there?" Well, you know,
there's a group of people that maybe
they have indicators from other
providers that or they have programming
done for NT7 and they still want to stay
with NT7 because you know, it's a big
difference between NT7 and NT8 in terms
of programming. But before I begin, uh
let me just go through the brief
disclaimers per usual. This presentation
is for educational and informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor. Investors can
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. Past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. All righty. So,
this is uh the Euro currency this
morning and as you can see,
um you got the prominent point of
controls up here, here. So, you got uh
your divergence as well, which you know,
is is already programmed. But uh I just
want to talk about this little sell-off
here. So, you got resistance here,
double top, resistance, resistance, and
divergence, divergence. Yes, you do have
a supportive point of control here, but
you know, we sold off from our first uh
our first high
with the uh divergence and prominent
point of control, came down here to a
support, we rallied back up. We rallied
back up and you got prominent point of
control and resistance again. You know,
now some people like to throw stones and
say, "Well, yeah, you had to sell here
and then it was a buy, but then look, it
didn't go anywhere." Well, it's because
you got a sell signal here. You know,
sometimes people get married to the last
trade that they're in. You know, they're
they're in this trade and then they just
for whatever reason don't want to take
the next trade. You know, if you got a
signal, say you're long from here and
you've got
um you know, a short signal, you don't
stay long, you get out. At at the very
least, you get out. Um and you you'll
assess the situation get short. And what
you have here is combination of things.
You got your divergence and prominent
point of control, which I've always said
is is a nice trade setup. And then
you've got your ratio in the next bar.
So, you know, even without this
prominent point of control, your
divergence and your ratio, which is you
know, one of my bread and butter trades
that I've always talked about, um you
know, this is a great short opportunity
up here.
You know, this morning in in the Euro
currency.
And let me just uh show you some of the
other
uh features that we've added into it. Um
what do I want to show you? I'll show
you the uh
E-minis charts.
Uh so, you can see here, this is well,
this is last night.
I don't know where we at right now this
morning here.
Um you know, we got the multiple
imbalances in there showing you know,
here you got this morning at 5:00 in the
morning. Again, you know, the ratio and
divergence right from the high. What do
we do? We sell. There's your divergence,
here's your bearish ratio. This part you
don't have the prominent point of
control. What do you got? You sell off
from your high all the way down to your
low. I mean, it's not the biggest move,
you know, at this point at 5:00 in the
morning. We're only trading, you know,
21 and 3/4 down to the low at 14 here
um before we sort of
sort of hang around there and eventually
make new highs a little earlier. But um
you know, these are those are those
trades that I talk about all the time.
You know, here's a again, you know, this
is
this is the problem sometimes, you know,
when you when you're dealing with S&Ps
in the night session, you know, you're
talking a range from 20 down to uh 15
right about here, 14 and 3/4. So, it's
very tight range. Um you know, if if
you're
looking to buy or sell a
a top, a potential top,
yeah, I like to have a bit more um bit
more range. I mean, here you had a
ratio. I'm sorry, here you had
divergence and a prominent point of
control. Then it came down here and it
met a supportive prominent point of
control and it rallied back up here
where you got the
the um
the sell signal there. But uh you know,
you get sell sell signal, but you know
what?
It's more of uh you know, the Order Flow
tool is telling you, "Hey, this is a
potential short opportunity."
And yeah, you can see here yesterday
afternoon, you know, you got a swing
low, prominent point of control,
multiple imbalances and we you know, we
rally up going into the uh into the
futures close.
Uh
you know, what else was there? This is
you know, what else can I show you?
Uh
I know, I'll show you the uh
I think it's a little bit better, a
little more clearer on a I'll show the
mini Dow chart.
See, let's take a look at this morning.
You might be able to see these
signals a little bit clearer here.
So, here you can see some sweeps here.
You see a sweep a sweep up, a sweep
down.
Um you know, that was the other feature.
Another sweep there.
Some sweeping activity going on in here.
Um see if there's any trapped traders
signals. Well, this it's
hard to get you know, decent signals
when the volume is very thin in the
evening session, but I'll take a look at
yesterday's main session.
I know, it's it's the color is is a
little bit different than these
than this purple.
Well, here's a trapped trader here. You
know, we did pop up make a new high by a
couple ticks before you you had a nice
sell-off from that high.
You know, it's just I don't want to say
it's you know, premature ejaculation,
but uh it's just premature here. These
guys are trapped. Market started coming
off, rallied back up. Didn't give the
trap signal there.
Uh you do got a bearish ratio.
Then the market sold off. So,
you know, what to do.
Yeah, down here you got another trapped
trader here, this green arrow. Um you
know, this was a nice one. This was
right on the cash open, 8:30 and 13
seconds.
You know, it sort of lines up with this.
It's almost a double bottom here. You
know, the first time you didn't get the
trapped trader signal, second time you
definitely did. You know, they're coming
down here to test the bottom, try and
take it a little bit lower, didn't work
out and then the market uh rallied up
from there.
Um let's take a look at the uh
five range Euro currency real quick.
Where are we here today?
Um
okay, let's go back to yesterday's.
Let's see. There were some interesting
things yesterday if I can remember.
Yeah, here you got a nice little double
bottom being formed. You got prominent
point of control. You don't get the
prominent point of control the second
time.
Here you got a double top. This one
failed.
Um here, this was another double top
with the prominent point of controls and
you got a nice little sell-off down
here.
Um
like I said, this one was interesting
cuz you had very nice very heavy volume.
Even if you look at the volume of this
bar, 18,000. Um here you're looking at
2,000, 3,000, 1,400. So, about
um you know, over 6,000 contracts traded
right here
to support this market.
Tested it again here. You know, people
say, "Well, you got prominent point of
controls here." Yeah, would would would
I be looking to get short these versus
getting long these um blue ones? Get
short the red versus get long the blue?
Well,
you know, when when I see a situation
like this,
look at the volume.
You know, I I judge it well, which is
stronger. In this sense, you know, I'm
willing to take you know, 2,000, 3,000,
1,500
more than 157, 70, 17 or 263, 178 and
four. Even here, 288, 74, 81. Yeah, this
this little pocket here is much stronger
than these two put together.
Um but I know that back here there
there's very strong support. Even we
come back down here, we can't even get
down um offered at this level again.
And you see how the market starts moving
back higher, higher, higher.
Anyway, that's what I wanted to talk
about with the uh NT7 version of Order
Flows Trader 2.0. You know, we've added
the prominent point of controls, the
multiple imbalances, the uh sweeps, the
enhanced trapped traders.
So, enjoy. Bye-bye.